nobody likes an elitist oh right if it
seems like it's been not that long since
I did up on animation junkie episode
it's because this is not a typical
animation junkie so this is this month's
patreon sponsored review that's right
hop on over to patreon and it is in fact
possible for you to support me at a tier
that allows you to just flat-out tell me
what to review and I will so um this
month I'm gonna be taking a look at an
animated film that I like quite a bit
and from back in the days when Warner
Brothers DC was consistently reliable as
opposed to now only occasionally be good
and we have Superman versus the elite I
love this movie
I mean this is a great story as well I
would encourage people to seek out the
the comic book story that this is based
off of which was called what's so funny
about truth justice and the American Way
so I'm gonna talk about this and I will
eventually talk spoilers because I'm
gonna want to talk about the the climax
of this thing but let's start with the
nice big broad strokes this is the movie
that I like to point to and and say you
know what watch this for anybody who
ever tries to make the claim that
Superman as a boy scout
doesn't work is irrelevant you know
isn't interesting there's nothing you
can do with him
anyone who makes that claim I
immediately go have you seen Superman vs
the elite because you need to see
Superman versus the elite because it for
me it is in the span of what is this
seventy five minutes yeah there abouts
yeah no not even seventy four minutes
this makes the case for why Superman
being the Paragon being the ideal
and living by the ideals that he has is
not only a key part of his character but
is vital to having him function and
having and if you ever take that away he
doesn't work and so the story give is
that a new group of sort of upstart
superheroes has emerged and they call
themselves the elite it is a four-person
team consisting of a man who sort of has
energy absorption and disparate and
blasts powers his name's cold-cast
there is a magic user called the Hat who
can literally pull anything out of his
hat from a bottle of booze to a dragon
there is a woman that called Menagerie
whose body is kind of she basically has
a parasite she can control it's all
these little sort of things that she can
send out and to attack people or they
can form like a wings for her and and
stuff like that and then this team is
led by Manchester black who is a
telekinetic and telepath actually now
that I stop and think about it he is not
that far from being DC's answer to Jean
Grey as far as power set goes but so
very powerful telekinetic powers and in
a very powerful telepath and they show
up and they're a bit rough around the
edges they're new to trying all this
they're kind of sloppy but their hearts
in the right place they want to help but
as time goes on Superman is seeing the
path that they're going down and
realizing they don't want to just uphold
the law they want to be the law they
want to do they want to be able to
dictate what the law is they they
believe that it is not only sometimes
okay that maybe it's even the correct
thing to do to just kill bad people
and that sets them on a road to
confrontation now that as far as how far
into the film things actually start to
go that way for a film this short you
know it's about 20 25 minutes in so I
would have actually considered that a
minor spoiler except one of the few
couples I do have with this is the title
it's that it's Superman versus the elite
I wish they I wish it had been named
Superman and the elite because I feel
like putting the vs. in there gives the
game away just on the title that what
this is going to come to now that's not
to say that even if you didn't know that
if you didn't have that title you
wouldn't necessarily go they're gonna
come to a head eventually but when the
title is vs then you're kind of just
waiting okay when is it going to
escalate to if I like you know for
certainty as opposed to going I'm pretty
sure no you know it's in the title so
that's one of my few complaints now I do
understand why they they didn't go with
the original title what's so funny about
truth justice and the American Way is
actually a great title but it's not a
very snappy one for for a movie but I
wish they call the Superman and the
elite I wish that's what they've gone
with so but that's that's your basic set
up and there's there's a little bit
other stuff in there this is this is
pretty this is not even pretty it is
distinctly solidly a Superman story
you're not getting other heroes showing
up he doesn't call in the Justice League
we don't check in with Batman there's
none of that and actually in terms of
recurring villains the the main one that
they have was one that I hadn't heard of
prior to watching this guy a guy by the
name of atomic skull it's pretty much
exactly what he sounds like
and so yeah I mean you've got that and
there's like already you get a little
glimpse of like dr. light and some other
stuff so there's plenty of stuff for you
know causing problems but the thing is
in this movie and what makes it so good
is that it's not just about Superman
coming into conflict with these other
heroes and their methods it has to do
the world becoming skeptical that
Superman's way can work and the world
starting to side with the elite and
think that their way of doing it is the
right way to do it and I almost started
tell you about the climax I will hold
off on that for long as I possibly can
but it really does dive into the
importance of Superman's worldview and
as philosophy and his feeling that life
is worth preserving and you know he
won't make the exception for the one
person out of a thousand who is a truly
awful human being that some of us would
probably think yeah maybe that person
should be wiped clean he won't make that
exception because he knows he believes
that it is more important to be sure to
preserve everyone because the minute you
make that exception for one person
you'll make it for another and another
and then how do you gauge how do you
keep your Center how do you keep your
moral grounding when you start to make
those kinds of exceptions and it's a
really good performance for Superman
both in the voice and in the animation
because you get his frustration with
seeing the tide of public opinion turn
against him and in he's not naive he
understands why people are going this
way why they want this but it's still
really hard for him to see and it's done
really well and he has a great scene
about midway through with Pott Kent
that's just this just a terrific pocket
has a great line he said when people are
hurting
they'll be so quick to jump onto a
bandwagon and they won't pay attention
to who's driving it yeah that was that
was nice and and I think you know at the
time it was made certainly now it hasn't
stopped being relevant because one of
the things that's really nicely done
about Manchester black specifically who
has the leader of the
is sort of the main one we spend time
with he is charming and charismatic he's
kind of he's kind of a British punk rock
thing going on he's got dyed purple hair
he's got you know big earrings that look
like just hunks of metal on his ear you
know that's that's the kind of guy that
he is but he's kind of oddly charming in
that and he has that guy who just tells
it like it is guy who doesn't deal in
any BS and it does you you get that
appeal of the guy who cuts through the
bull crap and you know says what
everyone is really thinking
whereas Superman is the guy who's trying
very hard to rise above the things you
think but no you shouldn't say because
Superman is the is the part of humanity
that says well there's a reason you know
you shouldn't say that um or think that
or do that but it was a very good call
to have manchester black not be you know
some like over angsty goth looking you
know or your sort of doom cult looking
guy like it there's a ton of ways they
could have done this but going kind of
shaggy scrappy charismatic was a real
good call because it helps sell how the
situation and what's going on with the
world and this guy specifically
espousing his opposite while not
complete opposite but his opposition to
the ideology of Superman you can see
where people would latch on to pretend
part of it the message given the state
of the world that we see in the movie
but also because of who's delivering it
and that he has a charisma and he can
bring people into that fold and it is
just a really well-done movie that that
while being actually pretty for the for
the animated films pretty brutal at
times like it's uh you know I say it
shows what's why super
is important to be the idealist and be
the Boy Scout that's not to say that
this movie is fun and cuddly it's not
because the way that it shows why it's
important for him to be that it's by
showing you all this other stuff going
on around him showing you a world where
that is not the norm so that he stands
in contrast to it so I'm gonna start
getting a little bit more in displays
cuz I want to talk in more detail about
the climax cuz I love this climax so
much so here we go the whole thing with
Superman appearing to have snapped is so
brilliantly executed because you've got
Manchester black and the rest of the
elite fighting him they believe fighting
him to the death but Manchester bike
also kind of believes that Superman is
so stuck in his ways that he's gonna die
rather than cross a line and Superman
ultimately find out at the end he didn't
cross the line but he lets them think he
has he lets them think that he has taken
all the restraints off and he's just
going at them and they are the first
three are just taken out so quickly
because suddenly might makes right
becomes a lot less appealing when a
bigger guy shows up and you realize oh
crap I'm not top of the food chain
anymore it's funny how quickly the whole
idea of you know the people with the
power should wield it you know how
quickly that can turn on you once you
realize there's someone more powerful
than you so the way that that goes down
and the escalation and the sense of fear
and dread from from the elite from Lois
from the populace at large seeing or
believing that they see are seeing
Superman snap
see Superman become well more or less
become injustice Superman really
this original story does predate
injustice to be clear but it's
terrifying
honestly it's he's he's just sort of
stalking after manchester black and he's
got this one completely bloodshot eye
because manchester had like burst the
capillaries in his eye earlier and it's
unsettling and it should be because
that's the thing it is hammering home
the point Superman should never be this
and he won't be and he's not because
people tend to forget that Superman for
all the the touting of his strength and
his flight and the the heat vision of
the x-ray vision that he's also very
smart and he's very compassionate any
and if there's a solution where he can
basically do no harm he will do
everything he can to figure it out and
do that and that's ultimately what he
does here and it's perfect it's the
perfect way to deal with what it is that
he is confronting and what it is that
he's dealing with and what's what's
great about this is that it's not it
never sits down and stop sign has a
protracted conversation about the
philosophy behind this film in terms of
what's right and why Superman's version
of right is important especially you
know in a fictional universe where
someone like him exists nobody really
opens excessively on that there's like
little snippets here and there but
nobody ever sits down and lays out the
moral because this reaffirmation of
Superman is baked into the narrative
because you put him up against a group
of people who are going to not just push
him physically not just push him and
fight but push his moral code as far as
they possibly can break it if they're
able to and that's a good way to to show
how his moral code makes him who he is
by putting that at the heart of the and
again not in an expository way in a the
nature of the conflict all pivots and
depends on him keeping his moral Center
and it's really it's just it's just
amazing I really do like it aside from
the title I if I were gonna nitpick some
of the animation isn't the best there's
something about the animation on
Manchester blacks mouth I think it's
because he's the only character where
they fully defined a set of lips like
everybody else just kind of has that you
know the the line that you know that
opens and it articulates but he's got
he's got purple lips to match his hair
so he's you know his his lips are fully
articulated all the way around and
outlined and it looks a little weird but
I mean this is nitpicky
I think conceptually this is a great
story I think what it is setting out to
do is a really good thing to do and and
it's something that I think a lot of
these for lack of a better term old
fashioned they're super moral heroes
should have reaffirmed about them every
now and then with characters like this
like Captain America it's important to
remind us why they should stay the
Paragons that sometimes we mock them for
being so I think I'll wrap it up there
hopefully if you're this far into the
video you've seen the movie cuz I did
talk about stuff that I really think you
should have you should have already seen
it I hope you weren't hearing it for me
from the first time but whatever your
thoughts are Superman versus the elite
have you seen it would you think about
it whatever your thoughts are drop them
down in the comments and let's talk
about if there's a whole bunch of
buttons there for likes and subscribes
and all sorts of things plus a link to
the patreon down in the description and
a whole bunch of links besides check
them out if you feel like it and
remember
folks you're the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]